panic and Terror gripped everyone in the
foundation facility while everyone who
was still alive that is guards were
working tirelessly to fight back and
regain control of the building but they
didn't have enough bullets to suppress
the oncoming horn somehow a sample of
scp-008 that was being examined for
testing purposes had managed to spread
to one of the research staff before long
the very same researcher was now a
Mindless zombie a reanimated corpse that
had managed to bite several other staff
members spreading the infection it
didn't matter that this original carrier
was shot down by security Personnel it
had already done its damage and passed
on
scp-008 by now there were too many of
them to Simply Bonk each one on the head
and neutralize it the foundation
facility had gone into full-scale
lockdown an emergency quarantine to try
and limit the spread of the deadly virus
any exit to the outside world was shot
and would stay sealed night until
someone from the foundation could do
something but that meant the few
surviving members of Staff trapped
inside were at the mercy of the zombie
horn their options were limited scp-500
was known to perfectly cure those
infected with scp-008 but with all exits
locked it was impossible to get any of
the remaining scp-500 pills on site then
one of the surviving researchers one Dr
omal had an idea it was an insanely
risky planned one that the foundation
would never sign off on but desperate
times called for desperate measures
Gathering up the remaining security
forces that hadn't been infected with
scp-008 along with a research assistant
that had managed to escape the Zombies
Dr omell and his band of survivors
headed deeper into the facility while
the external doors were all locked to
prevent the scp-008 infecties from
making it out and spreading the virus to
The Wider world the doors inside the
facility were all still functioning and
it was a good thing too Dr omell's plan
relied on opening the doors to two
anomalies
scp-914 the Clockworks a machine capable
of destroying or refining anything
placed inside of it and
scp-049 the plague doctor it was a shot
in the dark at best homel had observed
the plague doctor for some time and knew
that the beak face surgeon was capable
of creating zombie-like creatures known
as
scp-049-2 not dissimilar from the
zombies infected with
scp-008 if anyone could potentially fix
this nightmare there were few as well
versed in anomalous medicine as
scp-049 taking him to the Clockworks was
however an even bigger risk normally
scp-049 killed any he touched and turned
their deceased bodies into a
cp049-2s hence Dr Romel calling for a
refinement of the plague doctors of
abilities placing him in the input Booth
of scp-914 and setting it to very fine
omel prayed he'd made the right call he
could hear the horde of scp-008 pounding
outside the locked door what emerged
from the Clockworks was still
recognizable as scp-049 retaining his
beaked mask although the mask itself was
actually flesh and Bone a part of his
skull his robes now float out behind him
as a pair of dark feathery Wings giving
him an even more bird-like appearance
despite this
scp-049 had claimed that he'd never been
a bird before I'll admit I didn't expect
Wings the surviving assistant remarked
that's not so surprising really Dr omell
admitted he did lay an egg that one time
he did what before an explanation could
be given the scp-008 zombies managed to
break down the door and came flooding
into the room homel recoiled in horror
as they snarled and shuffled closer
reaching towards him with decrepit
fingers suddenly scp-049 swooped into
the path of the encroaching Undead with
a flap of his new Wings calmly he gave a
gentle move of his hand like lifting
something from a shelf a bizarre
Contraption appeared around his forearm
a gauntlet connected to syringes that
were strapped to each of his fingers all
filled with various different fluids Dr
omell was amazed
scp-049 seemed to now have the anomalous
ability to summon surgical equipment
from a tiny pocket Dimension it was
almost exactly like how
scp-076-2 Abel drew his weapons reaching
towards the nearest
scp-008 zombie still moving with the
utmost calm
scp-049 stated now try to hold still he
spoke in a gentle voice with the bedside
manner most medical doctors would be
incapable of This Might Sting a little
with that scp-049 pushed the syringes
into the zombie the fluids draining from
each one then refilling as he withdrew
his hands the scp-008 instance froze for
a moment almost like it was confused
before it began to emit what looked to
be steam as though it had stepped out of
a hot shower shaking uncontrollably the
necrosis and telltale signs of
infections seem to disappear like being
washed away until all that was left of
the scp-008 zombie was the infected
researcher it had been before the man
was alive and well much to Dr omell's
astonishment
scp-049 hadn't just cured the scp-008
infection he'd actually reversed it
leaving the infected alive and well it
took a few hours for scp-049 to fly
around the facility on his new Wings
effortlessly turning all the scp-008
zombies back into their old selves one
by one by the time he was done everyone
on site that had previously been exposed
to scp-008 was cured and it didn't stop
there the foundation still mandated
everyone who was previously infected to
remain in quarantine whilst they were
examined demanding the now refined
scp-049 to remain in a Cell which he
politely complied with when the SCP
Foundation doctors took a look at the
formerly zombified staff they were
amazed at what they found each one had
all traces of scp-008 completely removed
from their systems trying to re-expose
them to the virus their bodies now seem
to be able to generate anomalous
antibodies that rejected and fought off
infection by scp-008 in a manner of
seconds the plague doctor had made
everyone immune upon further testing
examining skin and blood cells from the
former infectes and Performing full top
to bottom health checks the foundation
doctors learned something else too
everyone that scp-049 had cured was even
healthier than they had been before one
security guard had been a 1 pack a day
smoker for 10 years but an x-ray
revealed any damage to his lungs mouth
and throat had all been completely
reversed on every possible internal and
external level the formerly zombified
Personnel had all been returned to
pristine Health by a cp049 eager to
witness the full extent of these new
anomalous abilities the Clockworks had
given him the SCP Foundation struck a
deal with scp-049 if he performed a
mission for them then they would provide
him with the means to have anything he
wanted for a moment the plague doctor
pondered their terms and then agreed
what is it you want in return Dr omell
had asked to cure the world
scp-049 replied simply the plague doctor
flew as fast as his wings would carry
him to the location the foundation had
given him it was an isolated region in
Siberia kept completely cut off from the
rest of the World by guards working
around the clock arriving at the edge of
the Frozen town
scp-049 was approached by the security
commander and given his full directive
from the foundation irreductive I'm told
is simple you enter the restricted area
and neutralize anything you come into
contact with when you're done return
here and we'll report the results to
command thank you Commander the plague
doctor nodded graciously you have been
most helpful you didn't ask what was out
there really turned and began walking
through the snow until he could no
longer be seen by the eye maybe he had
already sensed what was out there what
kind of sickness plagued to this place
and understood exactly what the
foundation were asking him to do if
scp-049 had any questions he did not
make them known instead he just headed
off in search of every instance of
scp-610 he could find that was quiet for
an uncomfortably long while the person
outstanding guard at the edge of the
area watched through the snowfall ready
if anything started slithering its way
towards them the foundation security all
tensed when the motion sensor picked up
movement accompanied by the sounds of
fighting and the bizarre inhuman noises
from instances of scp-610 then after
another long period of unsettling quiet
somebody spotted a gently glowing light
making its way through the snow as it
drew closer the glow of a burning
makeshift torch made it clear that the
figure holding it was scp-049 and as he
made his way towards the Rendezvous
point it quickly became apparent he
wasn't alone shivering in the freezing
cold and wet from the snow covered in
scraps of dirty clothing and whatever
else they could find was a huddled mass
of people all of them looked bewildered
following the light of scp-049's torched
like a guiding Beacon towards the edge
of the perimeter the foundation security
all stood slack jot in amazement at what
happened while the plague doctor led the
people and urged the commander that they
all needed warmer clothing immediately
he had done it
scp-049 had cured the flesh that hates
in the coming months the foundation soon
found themselves very busy everyone who
had previously been infected by scp-610
needed to be screened and examined just
to make absolutely sure there was no
chance they could mutate into a fleshy
monstrosity again but just like before
with the former scp-008 zombies these
people were in perfect condition cured
and healthier than they had ever been by
using his new anomalous surgical skill
and healing power
scp-049 had returned the flesh that
hates victims back into human beings it
was starting to seem like there was no
disease no infection anomalous or
otherwise that he could not cure the
foundation began an effort to re-house
the former scp-610 infectes given that
most of them had spent years as
aggressive anomalous Abominations almost
every one of them had officially been
pronounced dead and couldn't just go
back to their old lives the SCP
Foundation gradually reintroduced them
into the world setting up new identities
and integrating them into new countries
scp-049 even personally helped console
some of those that struggled with the
adjustment offering to give them therapy
to Aid in the process he was more than
just a plague doctor at scene thanks to
the Clockworks
scp-049's good work didn't stop with
curing the flesh that hates either as
promised the foundation allowed him to
carry out his Newfound purpose whereas
before he was obsessed with eradicating
what he called the pestilence now the
plague doctors seem to be directing all
this Focus to curing the world as he put
it and he started with some of his
fellow anomalies the plague doctor
started experimenting with his new tools
concocting cures and serums aplenty by
pulling whatever he needed from an
endless supply of equipment and
ingredients at his fingertips he
developed a cure for the condition that
caused Daniel McIntyre to become
scp-2800 cactus man his skin reverted
back to normal no longer sporting spines
while the plant-like parts of his DNA
once again became human
scp-049 even offered a sympathetic ear
to a lot of Daniel's troubles giving him
therapy through a lot of his mental
health difficulties
scp-2102 was on also one of scp-049's
successful patients his condition of
rapidly overproducing new skin tissue
when injured quickly became a thing of
the past then the plague doctor turned
his sights to The Wider World working
tirelessly to create new vaccinations
and treatments for diseases that were
once thought to be incurable everything
he made and had the foundation
distribute to those that needed it was
all one hundred percent effective people
were healthier and happier than ever all
thanks to the plague doctor until they
weren't in attempting to eradicate
disease the world over a new strain of
illness emerged
scp-049 took to calling it a new
pestilence and it was nothing short of
horrific it would have been considered
anomalous at one time but it quickly
became so widespread that it couldn't be
contained all the plague doctors
Advanced Medical Treatments had
encouraged this disease to mutate to
adapt against everything he could throw
at it it could infect any person at any
time and present itself with virtually
any symptoms it resisted drugs any form
of treatment and it spread rapidly
eventually while trying to come up with
a way to protect people from the strain
of super bacteria this new pestilence
scp-049 started to fall ill he had
caught it and even with his refinement
he was beginning to weaken the plague
doctor was dying and once he was gone
the whole world would soon follow as
more and more people caught the sickness
there was only one thing he could do a
way to leave someone behind to carry on
his work when the foundation those that
weren't yet ill found scp-049 had
already passed but alongside his body
was something smooth and pearlescent an
egg and inside maybe a chance for the
world to be cured once an anomaly of
your own check out scpswag.com for high
quality SCP merch now go check out what
if the flesh that hates was put inside
scp-914 and scp-049 boiled scrambled and
fried plague Dr tail for more pestilent
entertainment